OF AUSTIN WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE SCRAMBLING COME THE RESINS
THEY ARE WORRYING.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THIS FEDEX STORE HAS BEEN AT THE
CENTER OF WHAT IS AN
INCREASINGLY URGENT SEARCH FOR
WHOMEVER MAY BE BEHIND THE
BOMBINGS WITH FEDERAL AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOCUSING ON THIS
AND AT LEAST TWO OTHER MAJOR
INVESTIGATIVE SITES AS THEY SEEK
TO BRING AN END TO AUSTIN'S
TERROR.
>> WE'VE BEEN WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK, AGAIN, THE PUBLIC SAFETY
IS OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
>> SAFETY THAT WAS ONCE AGAIN
CHATTERED AFTER ANOTHER
EXPLOSION IN TEXAS.
THIS TIME, AT A FEDERAL EXPRESS
FACILITY IN SHERTZ, 20 MILES
OUTSIDE OF SAN ANTONIO.
>> THE PACKAGE HAD BEEN
TRAVELING ALONG THE AUTOMATED
CONVEYOR WHEN IT HAD EXPLODED.
ONE EMPLOYEE THAT WAS STANDING
NEAR THE EXPLOSION LATER
COMPLAINED OF RINGING IN THE
EARS.
>> THE FBI BELIEVES THE PARCEL
WAS DESTINED FOR AUSTIN.
THEY ARE NOW INVESTIGATING AN
AUSTIN AREA FEDEX STORE FOR
WHERE THEY BELIEVE THE PACKAGE
WAS SENT TO.
THIS COMES JUST TWO DAYS AFTER A
BLAST IN THE STATES CAPITAL
INJURED TWO MAN.
SUNDAY'S BOMBING SHOWING WHAT
AUTHORITIES CALL A "HIGHER LEVEL
OF SOPHISTICATION."
IT WAS TRIGGERED BY A NEARLY
INVISIBLE TRIPWIRE.
>> THEY LOOKED SO HARD, THEY
COULDN'T TELL, THEY TRIPPED AND
SET OFF THIS EXPLOSION.
THEY DIDN'T SEE IT.
IT WAS A WIRE.
AND IT BLEW UP.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT TO THINK
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS
WITH SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN
HAPPENS.
IT'S UNCALLED FOR.
>> THE PRESIDENT ECHOING THAT
SENTIMENT AND OFFERING SUPPORT
FROM WASHINGTON.
>> THE BOMBINGS IN AUSTIN ARE
TERRIBLE.
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL WORKING
HAND-TO-HAND TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A VERY, VERY
SICK INDIVIDUAL OR MAY BE
INDIVIDUALS.
ARE SICK PEOPLE AND WE WILL GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
>> WITH A SERIAL BOMBER AT
LARGE, HUNDREDS OF AGENTS FROM
THE ATF AND FBI AND ON THE
LONE STAR STATE AND RACING
AGAINST TIME, HOPING TO STOP
THE PERSON WHO HAS KILLED THE
TWO PEOPLE AND INJURED FOUR
OTHERS THIS MONTH IN AUSTIN AND
WHO SOME INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE
IT IS LIKELY LINKED TO THE DAYS
BOMB BLAST IN SHERTZ.
>> CERTAINLY COMMON SENSE TELLS
YOU THAT IT'S VERY LIKELY
CONNECTED AND I THINK WE WILL
FIND OUT SOON THAT IT IS
CONNECTED.
>> OFFICIALS SAY IT IS CLEAR
THAT WHOMEVER IS DOING THIS HAS
CONSIDERABLE EXPERTISE.
WHAT ISN'T CLEAR IS THAT MOTIVE
AND TO MORE FRIGHTENINGLY,
PERHAPS, WHEN AND WHERE THE
BOMBER WILL STRIKE NEXT.
BRET?
>> Bret: JONATHAN, LEAVE THIS
AFTERNOON, THE AUTHORITIES CAME
BACK AND SAID THAT WAS NOT AN
UNEXPLODED DEVICE, SO THEY
WERE HOPING TO GET ONE THAT WAS
INTACT.
BUT THEY CAME OUT AND KIND OF
CORRECTED THAT.
>> YES, THE POLICE CHIEF IN
SHERTZ HAD ORIGINALLY PUT OUT A
STATEMENT SAYING THAT THEY HAD
FOUND A DEVICE THAT DID NOT
EXPLODE OUT OF LARGE FEDEX
FACILITY JUST BY SAN ANTONIO.
THEY WALKED BACK BACK WITHIN
ABOUT TWO OR THREE HOURS AND
SAID THEY HAD NOT FOUND A SECOND